The web service layer refers
to the protocols that can sit
on top of the application layer and
can determine the format in which
APIs are sent and received.
One of the most popular protocols
at this level is the simple
object access protocol, or SOAP.
SOAP uses the extensible markup language
to transmit sets of information
in the form of objects.
SOAP most commonly sits atop
the HTTP application protocol, but
can also function with SMTP, or
the simple male transfer protocol.
REST, a representational state transfer,
is the up and
coming alternative to SOAP.
REST is more of a set of styles and
guidelines than a protocol,
since it leverages the features of
HTTP in order to transmit information.
HTTP verbs like GET, POST, PUT, and
DELETE, handle the management
of a server's resources.